hi we're recording and were perfectly
normal people just before we started
recording everyone go ahead I have in
five almost five hours but it's been two
days at that point where like you have
like manic energy yeah you're gonna
crash soon that's why we record now
Oh Evan Caitlin podcast where as sleep
deprivation is a key ingredient that's
why I pause the music's play alright
guys so today we want to think our very
first podcast sponsor will tell you more
about them later but in this episode we
are gonna give a little health update
we're gonna take about the vacation we
almost took we are going to maybe fit in
some bonus topics and the game is gonna
be another song game my favourite kind
of game the best and we're gonna try to
identify movies based on an iconic song
from that movie yes yes there can be any
okay quick health update I am better
which is really good news it only took
two misdiagnosis
yeah like so many trips to the doctor's
anyways the the good news is that I'm
all better and I'm ready to keep on
going thank you so much for everyone
who's left well wishes for me to get
better and yeah let's just jump into it
so vacations yeah so this was this was
something that's been on our minds a lot
we we used to take vacations fairly
frequently your trips a big like
two-week vacation every year where we
would go somewhere far and well I guess
I'm just gonna start
to be as frugal as we can throughout the
year throughout the music that was like
are like big treat to ourselves yeah you
know and we haven't taken a vacation
like that ever since we started the
channel the channel and we really wanted
to get like one of those in in 2019 and
right okay you know we figured out where
we want to go we want to go back to
Thailand and that's all another topic of
like people are you shouldn't go back to
the same place but it's like so good we
have talked about Thailand is where we
went on our honeymoon and it's been like
our favorite place that we've ever gone
yeah we just want to go back to the
exact same place literally the exact
same magical but the you know in
Thailand there's a rainy season so
there's a time when you should go and
there's time when you shouldn't go in
and the rainy season is like half of the
year so it's like we would have had to
leave on the vacation in like three
weeks
yeah well the rainy season is from April
through October and so it would have to
be in March February is like halfway
over you know it's like we realize this
not that long ago and we've already made
a lot of plans and commitments and okay
let's try to squeeze it in we blocked
out a week and well it's a two-week
vacation but we were like we have we had
already committed to so many sponsor
commitments that we could only take off
one week from actually doing a video
we'd have to get one week ahead and then
skip a week which are both difficult in
their own ways very difficult and we we
like to I mean both of us are ideally
highly planned people oh yeah in the
best in the best case scenario if it's
up to us we would like to plan well a
lot of things out so when I'm on a
vacation I don't want to spend time on
the vacation like googling yeah you were
all laid out all the resources available
not laid out in terms of like I don't
want to plan all my days out but I want
to have already done the research so
that we feel like we want to go to you
know an elephant sanctuary we yeah the
one that treats the elephants right and
everything lor
if we want to go out to eat we already
have places near our hotel starred and
see this like it's like go there don't
download it offline
yeah we're not like in the hotel room
Google and the way to go we're like okay
it's time to eat let's go to this place
that's near us boom yeah and it's like
adventure yeah yeah so so like planning
a trip like this is a huge multi-day
undertaking I'm not sure if that is all
that is like after you've chosen the
place and we wanted to do a two-week
trip so we were gonna get you're gonna
do one week at the place that we had
already gone to in Thailand which was
Krabi Thailand and then we were gonna do
one week somewhere else in Southeast
Asia yes area yeah so planning vacations
is like a like I was like a 2 day 2 days
of like figuring out where to go maybe
another 2 days of research more than two
days for you I'm just like laying out
like a bare minimum here that's coming
up way too soon we need to get farther
ahead on videos to do it yeah and we
have like some very exciting
opportunities coming up that we just
couldn't say no to and we'll get into
some of that more later but I just
wanted to tell this whole story we like
went through this whole thing yesterday
and in the weeks prior
struggling with us and I thought it
would be an interesting thing to share
another indicator of kind of what led us
to this decision is when when I was sick
a little bit ago throughout me you're
not feeling well we kept on filming just
because we felt like we couldn't stop we
had already made commitments and if we
if we just took a break then would they
have to pay for that and I just also
didn't want to stop I personally didn't
want to I just would feel like not
satisfied if I wasn't doing what I
wanted to do well the same thing for the
last week as well because we've both had
a cold and
pretty attempts it was pretty intense we
like could I was talking about this
somewhere I don't owe and it was in the
app it was in the page but we were like
at that point where like your nose is
running so much that you just have to
put tissue plugs up your nose wads of
tissue like literally stuck up in our
nose and we're like okay that's saying
dry it okay it's time to fill in the
next scene okay pop out your plugs take
a break to blow our nose it was bad but
like yeah I think we were like between
you know you being being sick a bit ago
and then like us both things like this
past week it's still being at the point
where like we felt like we couldn't stop
working it's like what makes us think we
can take it to vacation why we are
working through not feeling well is
because we knew we have this vacation
potentially planned that's yeah and we
have like a trip coming up in a few days
work times con the week after this
podcast comes out but we week of this
podcast you guys there yeah but anyway
we have another April your spring make
and then of course there's the the
delays and you know like products coming
in and we can't work in the videos that
we need to because of other delays
anyways all of that building up to the
point where we were just like we just
couldn't we just couldn't or didn't feel
like we could because we just didn't
have the spare time didn't feel like we
could take a break yeah yeah yeah and I
think that you know of vacation costs
money and time you know we we try again
we try to be frugal and not spend money
on too much and we try to savor for
those vacations so we have the money set
aside for vacation right now and that's
not a problem but if you think about
time in the same way you think about
money it's like let's say that we use
money as the thing that we had saved up
and we spent it all or went into debt
with our money that might not like let's
say we had
zero dollars and we've saved up just
enough to go on vacation and we spend it
all on the vacation that wouldn't be
advisable yeah you know but if you take
that same thing and equated to money
let's say that we had me equated okay
everyone knows your brains only like
let's say that we have zero spare hours
per day which is kind of accurate I mean
you know we take tiny breaks for like
you know we go and walk meetings we go
and walk meetings we watch some YouTube
every now and then we hop on reddit
every now and then you know we cook we
cook yeah it's not like you know if you
think if you look at our time bank like
like like an extra time bank I don't
know we have like zero money's zero
times in the bank and we've been carving
out time for our future spend you know
and if we carved out just enough to go
on the trip and we spent it all on the
trip and we got back down to zero I
think it might be a similar thing if
like you look at the value of going on a
vacation versus spending at that time on
something else that's also important and
I think that you know a vacation does
have short-term and long-term benefits
because while we're there
hopefully we're relaxed we're having fun
we've taken care of everything this we
can just like turn off and I think
that'd be healthy short-term and
long-term because if we I think about
some of the vacations we've taken they
like sustain me long-term yeah you know
I still think about them in a very nice
way so I think that vacations do have a
long-term benefit but I also think about
like all of the long-term items that we
just keep on putting off that are
important for us our life you know all
sorts of things because you know we've
made these like all these commitments
that are trying to keep up with them and
we just don't have any like all we're
doing are urgent and important we're not
doing anything that that's important but
not urgent
yeah and evan is referring to like the
the urgent versus important matrix where
you have you know on a need to do item
or any to-do list
it can be urgent and important urgent
not important not important not urgent
I'm already lost but one thing that I
think we've been really good at doing is
eliminating the urgent and not important
things from our life we try to we try
sometimes so like get sucked into
something then because it seems urgent
but then we realize it's not that
important because like that's the
easiest thing to get pulled into the the
urgent and not important things those
are the things that distract you and can
really take up a lot of your time and
we've been trying to get get rid of that
that like the or not urgent yet very
important are some of the most important
things yeah it's long Turtles
yeah long-term success and and and if we
take care of some of those I think we
might be able to free up more of our
time in the future maybe yeah well I
think it's it's tough cuz um you know we
do set our own schedule it's just you
know it's it's hard in the moment to be
a judge of how overcommitted you're
gonna be later on yeah you know and it's
a lot easier to say yes to things than
to say no to things especially when
you're somewhere where you're trying to
like grow your business you know you
don't to be saying no just stuff it's
very counterintuitive and so even though
we do set our own hours like we do also
make real actual commitments to people
and it's not just we can't just be like
oh well we don't feel like doing that we
would rather go on videos yeah this is a
complicated thing and I think that that
um you know looking from the outside
it's completely understandable to say
like well you make your own schedule and
just take the days off you know and
that's that is true we do make our own
schedule and we could as take time off
but like Caitlin said we were already
committed out through half this year
yeah pretty much
yeah we like videos planned
and into May and we've made commitments
yeah starting June we're starting to
make June so it's like for that period
we can't like we can't really change too
much change too much and if we take time
off that means we're gonna have to
hustle extra hard to keep up with the
schedule we've already set for ourselves
yeah because like when when you let's
say you do realize like you know and we
kind of hit this towards the end of last
year because there were a couple months
last year where we were releasing six
videos a month and it was definitely too
much but by the time we realized or at
the time when we realized it was too
much like when we were in the middle of
it there was nothing we could really do
about it we could say okay once we're
done with these commitments we'll make
sure not something that again but in the
moment there's no fixing it because we
schedule so far out and and the
relationships we want to form with the
companies that we work with that's very
valuable to us you know we get 60% of
our income from working with sponsors
and that's what allows us to do the
things that we do you know and I think
we could do this full-time if we didn't
have sponsors and we would've had to
wait a lot longer and you have been able
to make as many as many pieces of
content as we have so working with
sponsors lets us make more content and I
think it's a win win win for everybody
but if we if we you know mislead or you
know I have to like reschedule somebody
too many times and like or have to back
out we've never had to back out of us I
would much rather over deliver to a
sponsor than under deliver ya know and
and but that's why I like even though
technically we are our own bosses and we
set our own schedule
we are still beholden to others yeah you
know so we can't just like switch things
around yeah and maybe in the future
we'll get to a point where we don't have
to have as many sponsors and then like I
don't think we'll ever just like say no
to sponsors completely but I could see
is getting to the point in a future
where we don't have so many yeah
III think that'd be nice and we've
talked
about it before it'd be nice if we maybe
had three sponsor videos a month so we
have like a flex week yeah like we could
just do something random for that week
or if we need to pick it off or you
could use it to help like things around
something gets delayed we can have that
slot held in reserve for it and
everything yeah I think that would be
like a really great way to do things I
think that one thing that taking on this
business and these the the scope of work
we've taken on has made me realize is
when people say I don't have time for
that what they're saying is that's not a
high enough priority yeah yeah because
you know you have time for him you have
time for things and and if something is
a high enough priority you will find
time for it we spent an hour changing a
tire yeah that evening that we had a
spare hour but changing that tire was a
high priority so we did it's just a
matter priority and right now the high
priority thing in our lives is to grow
the channel get it sustained a
sustainable level you know and all of
all of that stuff and that will let us
be able to have more flexibility in the
future yeah I mean we're hoping like all
the hustle and groundwork and long hours
and stuff now will make us better set up
in the future and not just get us
addicted to working because it's hard to
be like hmm I feel good about where I am
now I'll just take weekends off well I
think that if we were like a few videos
ahead and we had we were taking care of
ourselves more and you know all of the
things that we want to change I think
that we would like if we were hitting
all of the goals I think that we would
be okay yeah we do just keep on adding
stuff that makes me feel more complete
yeah
we do and I like the things that we've
added but yeah but it is hard to imagine
being at a point where like we were
consistently like enough videos ahead
that we felt comfortable taking weekends
and taking those weekends didn't eat up
our lead yeah that's hard to imagine
that's that is I know people do it yeah
but I mean like like let's say we cut to
like three videos a month and then we
could do it but you know we already like
have so many ideas we want to tax
emergency on these ideas cause right oh
that's a really good idea gotta do it
before somebody else does it I had one
of those last night no so excited I said
research in bed I mean it's good
excitement and it is good good things
yeah but like but I guess what I'm
saying is if we were only doing three
videos a week then we would be planned
out through like October we wouldn't be
able to do those new videos until
October right now we're like week and
even even more picky about our video
ideas maybe but it's hard because like
sponsor sponsors you have to do the
project that you pitched we're really
excited about like the one that you're
talking about it's a little bit
different it's a little different more
unknown and so you don't know how it's
gonna perform in your sponsors you know
if you promise a certain amount of views
and you don't hit it then they're not
gonna want to work with you again yeah
and that's that's painful yeah and that
yeah that's bad
so you know you can't be as risky yeah I
mean I feel like we've like varied away
from vacations and stuff this is more
like time management yeah I mean
yesterday we did talk a lot more about
like vacation specific stuff were there
any like standout points that like
helped us come to this decision okay I
think it was ultimately like deciding
not to do the vacation in the next few
weeks was the thing but like both of us
were kind of hoping for an excuse to
come up so that we put it off till later
this year which sounds weird
but but we were like you know I hope we
look up the prices and it's just way too
expensive right now cuz it's so
last-minute like that's what we were
both saying I think that like the reason
why we wanted at that choice to be made
for us instead of just making the
decision ourselves which we ended up is
doing is because not going on the trip
is the easier option in a way yeah and
and well it's like you feel you it's
weird because you kind of feel guilty
either way you do feel great the other
way if you go on the trip you feel
guilty because you know like you you
know you're not putting that time
towards something you know that is work
productive and like I kind of feel
guilty towards like my future self
because I know future self is gonna be
paying yeah for that fun yeah later on
you know cuz where it's always stressful
coming back from a trip but you also
feel guilty if you do the quote-unquote
easy thing which does not go on the
vacation just like keep doing what
you're doing and it's weird when it
feels like you feel guilty for not
taking a break yeah but I think that's
the reason like the the hope and in my
head is I think that we still might
potentially take that week break and use
that time that we're not putting towards
like the videos we have planned to make
changes and and work on things that we
want to change you know like yeah I
don't know I I think that that puts a
lot of pressure to and when Evans I was
like take that week you know it would
have been a two-week vacation but we
would have been technically taking a
week off from posting a video so your
meaning like take that week that we
would be working on that books video yes
yeah it puts a lot of pressure to use
that week super productively and come up
with all these brilliant brainstorming
ideas because then if you don't and you
end up just doing kind of like your
normal to do is it's like wow wow great
job guys yeah it's really so much better
than a vacation on a vacation or
something and you just think you can do
that you can't
yeah yeah but we are going to take the
vacation later this year
I know but part of me is like our army
but it's like okay so so let's like get
to the point where we can and it's not
this painful that's the goal that's we
will go on yeah
and we're getting closer to that I mean
last year oh yeah and you know 2017 also
there was there's no way there's no way
and we did a lot of trips but they were
all like collaboration trips or event
trips and there was just no fitting and
anything else and the thought of trying
to fit in was so stressful I couldn't
even couldn't even like comprehend it
yeah you know this is not an option but
also we were learning all sorts of
things like you know the best way to
work with sponsors and how to schedule
things and how to set up deals and yeah
we were everything you know so it's like
we have a lot more figured out now we
have a lot more figure it out and like I
do feel closer to the point of being
able to take a vacation but still part
of me is like are you really gonna take
it in November October or whatever later
this year are you gonna fill stuff up
all right well while we figure out what
we're doing next like um we we wanted to
thank our very first podcast sponsored
trade coffee we've worked with them in
the past and they're an amazing and
delicious sponsor I mean very tasty
because I don't know a type of coffee
that I like and they provide the answer
to that question yes they have an online
quiz where you can put in things like do
you like milk with your coffee how do
you like to make your coffee at home do
you like crazy flavors are more
traditional and it'll take those and
give you a coffee that is best suited
for you and then as soon as you order it
it's roasted to order you get sent to
your door
super easy yeah and if you are
interested in trying out some trade
coffee for yourself you can click the
link down in the description below on
the YouTube video or there are links in
the podcasts to like the show notes the
show notes yeah yeah and you can use
code Evan Caitlyn at checkout and you'll
get 50% off your order for the first
hundred people so yeah so
click it yeah beat those other Oh over a
hundred people ok good job thanks Jane
thanks dude
well one thing that I want to talk about
because we have an excuse to talk about
it and we haven't talked about it
anywhere else I think that sharing some
fun stories of our past vacations could
could be fun how he almost died actually
almost closes I felt 2 dying no thought
that we were gonna die so there okay so
here we were in New Zealand and there's
this tongariro hike I might be saying
it's an Alpine crossing it's like an
alpine crossing yeah I don't know what
the difference between that hike an
Alpine crossing is well I guess what
almost kills you an Alpine crossing I
think you'd go up over a mountain and
you cross it hmm hike is just like you
take some steps to a place then you go
back probably yeah um so I had read all
these awesome reviews and people are
like yeah you know what's long but you
can you can do it in like seven hours
and I was like you know what that's like
a like a day trip that's how people did
it unless some people didn't last but
like that were just like seven hours
okay that's that's a pretty big hike but
you know it got such good reviews and
when you get to the top there's these
like glacial pools at the top of the
mountain you go through all this cool
terrain you like go through a crater and
there's all this like cool volcanic
activity and awesome stuff and that was
true that was true except well there's a
few things well but I think they're like
people who are drawn to that type of
thing already a certain like physical
skill level yeah like if you're looking
at alpine crossings like chances are
you're at leave you're like an eight on
the lake and then one to ten physical
health level hikes to be going per year
it's like zero that's like before the
Alpine crossing that we try to take off
I've been hikes like on vacations when
was the last time you've done a hike
before the Alpine crossing
probably two years probably more for me
probably more for you because we have
never done a hike together and by that
point we have been dating for a long
time it's like you you go to TripAdvisor
and you look up these these like
beautiful pictures beautiful pictures
you like what's the best thing to do in
this area with this hike let's do it
because it says that it's good we're not
prepared in many ways first off like you
know you you get there you drop your car
off at the end point and then a bus
takes you to the beginning point and
then you have to hike back to your car
so you can't just like decide to turn
around on the bus we started noticing
things what did you start noticing I
started noticing that like everyone was
much more serious about their gear than
us
yes everyone had like actual hiking
backpacks and like camelbacks yeah more
water more layers yeah like it should
have been assigned to me we started the
hike you know it was fine thing it was
you know not too intense or anything
everyone was already passing us but it
should have been assignment I was like
I'm the only person in skinny jeans on
this and then like we had asked the the
like bus driver if we needed to bring
more layers and he was like that'll be
about the same as it is here and we're
like okay we're like we'll just put one
pair of gloves in our backpack just in
case and this is new in new New Zealand
and they're summer so it was like
relatively one and I'm not sure if you
guys have seen tiny backpack which to me
is a legend but it's like a five by nine
backpack yeah that I love and I've had
for years and I had tiny backpack and
you had another backpack yeah and like
like one or two snack bars well no our
lady hit me with yes we had like a
little packed like a very small packed
lunch and we have like two energy bars
but so so
anyway so we're like going up
everybody's passing us we're getting
pretty tired and there's no really
there's no way to tell how far along you
are no II didn't have GPS we didn't have
we didn't have GPS you know there's no
signal up there
oh oh this is this is the best thing I'm
not sure how we could ever release this
because it just doesn't fit anywhere but
we recorded a check-in every hour at the
beginning we are alright we're good we
had energy and there's just like a
descent into madness and like sleep
fatigue and like it's just like
literally by the end we were like loopy
we were loopy like in the in a weird way
yeah yeah it was yeah well it's probably
like the lack of water or lack of food
lack of energy altitude we were pretty
loopy and this was this wasn't just like
walking like there were parts and it
didn't like hold your hand either you
didn't get like guide rails and stuff on
steep things there were parts where
there was like a chain bolted into rocks
and you had to climb up the chain up
rocks and if you say you fell there are
you at the Laughing with a chain on the
side of a mountain and it's like if you
slip you're going down a mountain and
the wind gusts were the we blew the case
off of our camera I had a camera that
was attached to my camera and I was
holding on to the camera and the wind
ripped the case off my hair and like
threw it off this thousand foot drop
those like those like 15 beautiful Hey
yeah we're not exactly know you were
probably you're in your duct-tape shoes
no no I think I brought my real hiking
boots oh you're right you're right oh
and mine were like slightly too small
which I did sorry like they were like
excited like long skinny tips um all my
toes were bruised by the
oh my gosh it was fine going up but then
going down if you're going down a slope
every time you step your toes are
jamming into the front of your shoes
that was like the worst part for me yeah
I would I would rather have dealt with
the crazy winds and the crazy climbing
than just walking downhill I think that
by the time we got to the peak of the
climb we we were all right we took a
little bit of break we were happy we've
got like re-energized and everything it
was definitely a struggle going up and
there are many times where I was like
what have we done oh yeah there was well
like our car was at the end yeah yeah so
there's there's no turning back there's
and by the halfway point
you couldn't even turn at the beginning
but at the beginning if you walk back at
the beginning it's just an empty parking
lot yeah there's like like the beginning
of the day people get to the like start
and air-quote and then everyone leaves
like buses drop them off or whatever you
know it's just there's there's there's
no one that'll be there until the next
day what was your most like what have we
done moment on the climb up when we were
hunkering down behind the rock this is
like towards the peak the wind was so
intense it was so intense it was so cold
and like the gust of wind would
literally kind of throw you off balance
and we were starving we were thirsty so
we there was this big rock and we sat
down next to the rock and just tried to
like share a cliff you know it's what
was funny is when we got to like the
Emerald Pools was really cool that's
like the thing people hike to go see
there was um like a field trip and they
hit we didn't really realize this they
should come learn the hard way it's an
easy way in the hard way to get to the
pools the hard way is where you get
dropped off on one end and then you walk
all the way to the other the easy way is
you just go from the end you walk up to
the pools and then you go back so we're
seeing all these like elementary school
kids and were like what
like like is there something in the
water in New Zealand like everyone is
way more physically fit than we are like
also at that point I mean to be to be
fair to us we have been working on
office jobs for a hike well and we were
like at that point seven hours into a
what should have been a seven hour yeah
how long did it end up being 10 10 hours
10 hours I think that was supposed to be
like 6:10 I think those Lizzie six okay
we're slow it'll be eight and that's
that story of how we almost died yep
but we like they were seriously moments
when I thought like climbing the chain
what if we just like can't go anymore
what do we do away that like we can get
off the mountain like and someone come
in help us yeah I was like what do you
what do you do if you just can't keep
coming but there was a point on the way
down that we reach like a fugue state
yeah is that the right word yeah we're
really just we were like in the flow of
like being and paying and just pushing
it to do it and just walking and I'm
sure that's something that like runners
and long distance people feel a lot but
like we we were not used to piss and we
just like this kept on going and like
I'm really proud of us that we just kept
on pushing and we are our limits were
way farther than I thought it's like my
limit now like in terms of a hike since
we're not in shape when we don't do it a
lot I would say I'll be fine with like a
three-hour hike one and a half hours in
one and a half hours out maybe for four
hours total but like we just kept on
going and going and going and you just
pushed and your body can do it like I
know that my body can do that now I just
don't
yeah oh man yeah that was crazy remember
by the end we were just singing really
yeah that was like our mantra
yeah and then we got to our car and then
drove like two hours or three hours to
our next location yeah and had like
pizza and then passed out yeah you know
what you know I want to do I'm not sure
if I'm ever going to do this and maybe I
shouldn't say this is all but like I
kind of just want to like take that
story and make a story time with it and
all of the video clips and like upload
that somewhere yeah it'll be fun but
like I don't know where we would I mean
the second channel no one's gonna watch
I was like I'm sorry that was a fun
story to tell I didn't expect it to be
like so fun to like tell us right we
should be like story time podcast where
we just like tell stories yeah oh we
have some more vacation stories of the
game we cook we could tell stories or it
could play the game we'll do the game if
you guys want more stories let us know
and we can do like a story time episode
more vacation stories game show time
[Music]
do you think it is now alright so in
this game it's very similar to the music
game where we played some audio and we
had to guess what TV shows TV show was
from but now it's gonna be movies
so the first so so we picked this didn't
have to be the theme song of a movie I
mean movies is not quite the same we're
like a TV show has an intro song every
time so it could be the theme song or
just an iconic song from the movie and
last time we did this we got a copyright
claim like a slight distortion and we're
gonna try not to play the songs for too
long yeah so hopefully the distortion is
not too annoying it's light sorry in
advance all right you ready I'm not
looking
[Music]
that's all you're gonna give me Oh
ghostbusters it's from there's a few
songs that sounding intro ah where's
like oh it's similar it's like the
Fleetwood Matt song and also
bootylicious tell me that doesn't sound
like the beginning of the Rambo's on
what I told you first or sweetwood Mac
that's up san and then pull up Fleetwood
Mac see what Mac did before I think does
new child took it from Fleetwood Mac I
don't know the name of it is that one
winged uh I'm gonna say Fleetwood Mac
sounds like Rocky's no edge of seventeen
yes
[Music]
sing it Wow God that's the rabbit hole I
didn't know that right Wow do I really
good then see I told so you I can only
play this for a little bit well that's
all of them Batman I remember when the
song came out like my mom would listen
to it a lot and my brother is like kiss
Pyro's on the grave you know so my
brother we were pretty little when this
song came out and my brother thought it
was a kiss by a moose on the grave stuck
in head oh it's so good so much it's so
good they're close sounds like that
though I have one or two hard modes for
you too okay
the bus I was waiting Amish check I've
no play more
[Music]
is that your paws just like waving his
hand like he's pushing it okay
this action is an action abduction it's
action okay it could be Avengers it
could be and some of these I'm not sure
if you've seen but like you should know
them I the same doing for you Donnie
Darko yeah I just really like that song
IIIi know I know but I knew you know the
song but I don't know that you would
know it's from well I thought that's
from Donnie Darko but their wings yeah
they're pretty strongly linked right my
turn okay hey sister soul sister um
Lady Marmalade what's the movie I cook a
new face like the 0.25 seconds it takes
for my finger to drop down the thing is
you go you say stop it I solve it then
you play it again okay I know the song
is the Lady Marmalade
song what's the movie I didn't actually
see this movie as long it's all that um
dancing yeah dancing and it's not the
other one with all this is a place in
France Paris Paris yeah um oh it's like
what's that what's a makeup like you
know when psychics are like I'm seeing
I'm hearing it's the office of the
letter purple it's the color purple and
you know to some psychics colors might
be letters confirmable might be this is
the one I'm most worried about getting a
coffee strike any parents can get it
from that I'm sorry if that was too
quick for people to guess and I'm sorry
if you're listening with their kids now
stuck in their heads that's pretty good
cuz like we only saw frozen once yeah
but I mean everyone's heard the song I'm
balling I'm blowing through these pretty
quick like but I have to play this I
have two songs from this I'm gonna play
a little bit from each just in case
[Music]
this is the inch okay now this is like
the the theme song even though like how
should you listen to this either oh come
on
when I heard the first one I was good I
was like okay it sounds kind of like
Star Wars ish but sillier so it's
probably Spaceballs which I've only seen
like once or twice I know you've seen it
a billion times it plays at the end Oh
watch the lad I still got it sir we've
been I'm slowly converting you thank you
over I think quicker if you hadn't
played the second song oh this probably
Spaceballs and then I heard the second
song and I was like err they had their
okay some of these might be if you've
seen this movie you will associate the
song with the movie but I don't know if
like universally this song would be
associated with this movie
[Music]
I know the song I have no clue she is
like zero service give me clip think of
this think of the words he just said I
think think of the name Betty Boop the
movie what's in comes out in an iconic
battle and his name is Betty that's why
they play that song was like my space
balls like I watch it I watched it so
many times
me and my brother we just like space
balls like that was like our jam and me
and my brother that was a jam watch that
really like I had like hit you with that
one I knew it might be a little harder
for you yeah we do it like like four
seconds at a time I have no clue no more
you should know that I should it sounds
kind of familiar okay
the distortion throws it off a little
bit but you should still do it I can't
whistle
[Music]
no cool I'll go for it a little bit no
it's not familiar kind of do we have
give me a girl whistling it okay it's in
a violent movie Kill Bill yeah I think
that like that might not have been the
most iconic Kill Bill for me I didn't
say it was the most iconic song for a
movie I'm saying it's an iconic song
from
that's not really a song it's like a
tune like you should know it I said I
said it's pretty iconic I saw movie can
have multiple iconic okay well I'm gonna
give you some hard ones soon so you
better watch out
give me a moment okay I have two hard
ones and then I'm out okay
well dear then I have a couple more oh
my gosh right
you know it James Bond which one oh gosh
okay okay okay a little bit harder ready
for the hardest one mainly cuz I don't
know if you've ever seen this movie okay
and like you shouldn't know the song in
this movie but you know no judgments
there's some cheesy song in that one cuz
I was looking up songs and I was like it
sounds like it's really 80 have you seen
it
yeah come on I've seen this I mean I
know this song but I don't know like
[Music]
it's not gonna help me I don't know it
has airplanes in it yeah like an iconic
song from top yeah yeah oh okay here let
me give you alright let's do two two
more and then let's wrap it okay oh is
that Hannibal or something no it's like
some thriller it's scary yeah oh I know
I know it I know it I don't know you
know it I know it but I don't it's like
it's like it's not x-files it's not like
it's some thriller some yeah it's a
movie we said x-files those are sure
right oh no they made the x-files movies
- yeah oh this is not that I'm not sure
I watched it I know I'll give you a clue
right if you start saying the guests
that you just guessed and then change
what you're saying after the first
syllable you'll get it x-men keep trying
X extraordinary
[Laughter]
okay if you don't then Wow yeah yeah and
and you know like we have unlimited of
this we have like lots of fun stories
for like story time we could do song
games there's all sorts of things and
speaking of things let's tell it let's
tell everyone about our things of the
week yeah first yeah well you you just
washed your thing of the week so you can
you can share that I did so my thing of
the week is a video and it's on the
channel the modern rogue if you're not
familiar with them they have an awesome
channel and we did some collaborations
with them a little bit ago they're all
in their Channel but they just released
the third and final of those
collaborations where we show them how to
make knives out of like soft blades you
might think if you want like all of your
like everything in you to just cringe
safety wise watch this video like I
think that I didn't realize how much
like supervision Brian needed held it in
like an angle grinder with like a
cut-off wheel yeah it's it's pretty
awesome so we'll put a link to that and
the knife I made while we were there I
still use that night it's still like
mine mine's not really
at all I really like mine because it's a
really really thin blade you could put
the whole thing like in a boot well what
I like to do is okay so what thing do we
open the most boxes boxes you know it's
really good for cutting open boxes I
really thin like sharp knife with this
very sharp point at the end and this one
has all of that it's really great for
slicing through cardboard because if you
try to pull a knife through cardboard
it's it's it's too fat you know you're
pushing the cardboard out so there's a
lot of resistance so thin it is glides
right through cardboard yeah and another
like the second best thing for cutting
through cardboard is a utility knife you
know but the problem with utility knife
is it's short mm-hmm you know so you had
to like you know hold it really
precisely and stuff this you can stab is
chance drag and you can like slide it up
in an extended slide you know cuz
utility blade you can't go up and down
too much you could put in your boots if
you had a proper sheath guess that'd be
yeah so my thing of the week which I
haven't had as the thing of the week
before but I've been using it a whole
bunch is epoxy epoxy everything like so
many projects that were coming up with
and they were getting excited about our
epoxy related we're doing an approximate
videos we've done in the past or epoxy
I'm just like I just love epoxy it has
really cool a ton of awesome properties
it like dries really hard you can polish
it I'm learning how to polish it you
know I'm learning how to cast it soon
it's a really great ingredient to add to
anything we're gonna add it to you know
we're gonna add it to like a prop we're
gonna add it to like the kitchen we're
gonna add it to wood we're gonna add it
to we're gonna add it to the kitchen
we're putting it on a thing that will be
used in the kitchen yeah well you're not
like putting epoxy on the kitchen you
can mix like okay how with this you can
mix epoxy with wood metal 3d prints like
real life objects you can cast it you
can do so much
since cast you can work it even further
with woodworking tools or tools you
might have around yeah it's just really
cool let's say the only downside is it's
not a cheap material no but it's really
cool but it's really cool
and you can do so much with it you can
embed things inside of it you can tint
it you can do alcohol inks you can do
pigments yeah you can mix all of those
elements together that's pretty awesome
all right hey guys thanks so much for
joining us on this episode we I know we
kind of bounced around a decent amount
from like story times to topics to games
and everything it's it's really nice to
be able to do that though we just don't
have a venue for all of this in another
place and yeah yeah thank you guys for
listening um if there's stuff you want
us to talk about lettuce mental comments
and as always if you know you feel like
giving it a rating or review on iTunes
that'd be cool yeah we read all of them
we like have like an email that is sent
to us and like oh the podcast get real
excited yeah the podcast reviews are in
yeah so it really means a lot to us and
we appreciate it thank you guys
[Music]